as the biggest river in the world the
amazon is renowned for its unique
wildlife
there's the infamously carnivorous
piranha the elusive pink dolphin
and blind electric eels but perhaps
stranger than almost any other fish
is the arapaima the largest freshwater
fish in the world
they generally grow to be 3 meters long
and weigh
up to 200 kilograms for comparison
that's how big bottle-nosed dolphins
usually get
and the size of the arapaima is hardly
the most unusual thing about them
the closer you look the weirder they get
from bony tongues to ceramic scales
they've proven themselves to be among
the fittest of survivors
and if you were to observe them shortly
after their eggs hatch and their
offspring start swimming
you would see something that appears to
break the rules of biology
adult arapaima feeding their young with
their own
milk but scientists have struggled to
understand the strange adaptations and
behavior of the arapaima
because the fish have become
increasingly endangered due to
overfishing
luckily protecting the arapaima might
also lead to greater protections for the
amazon rainforest as well
making them not only a worthy subject of
research
but potentially the linchpin for the
conservation of the entire ecosystem
the earliest ancestors of the arapaima
were the first members of the
osteoglossomorpha super order
who appeared about 187 million years ago
in the early jurassic the name of this
group
literally means bony tongues indicating
that unique adaptation
at this point the fish weren't amazon
dwellers since the river didn't start
forming until 11 million years ago
around
23 million years ago the arapaima
assumed the form that it has today
making it among the oldest living
freshwater fish on the planet
and by this point it had a number of
adaptations that made it perfectly
suited for the low
oxygen freshwater river unlike most fish
arapaima get 90 percent of their oxygen
needs from the air instead of the water
they have a modified swim bladder which
functions almost like lungs
allowing them to suck oxygen from above
the water
they can even survive out of the water
for up to 24 hours
to understand just how remarkable this
organ is in
arapaima it's worth diving a little
deeper into swim bladders more generally
for most fish the swim bladder is filled
with air to help them maintain
buoyancy at different depths some fish
have swim bladders which are connected
to their gastrointestinal system
in this kind of fish like goldfish and
carp they gulp
air to inflate the swim bladder then
burp air to deflate it
in other types of fish swim bladders
aren't connected to the digestive tract
they empty and fill their swim bladders
by diffusing gas from their blood
for these fish the swim bladders have
nothing to do with breathing
they're more like flotation devices
these fish have gills that filter oxygen
from the water and then pass it into the
bloodstream
arapaima on the other hand have a very
large swim bladder that essentially runs
the length of their bellies
the organ is characterized by small
wrinkles which increases the surface
area to allow for better absorption of
oxygen
and when scientists studied the tissue
that lines the arapaima swim bladder
they found it was very similar to the
tissue seen in the gills of fish that
don't breathe air
this swim bladder isn't a true lung like
you'd see in a mammal but it serves a
very similar purpose
despite having gills arapaima drowned
within 10 to 15 minutes if they stay
completely underwater
this might seem like a weird adaptation
for a fish
considering they live in the water but
it's actually a good survival strategy
if you live in branches of a river like
the amazon that regularly floods its
banks when the river infiltrates the
forest
during the annual wet season the water
is filled with decaying vegetation
this creates highly anaerobic conditions
in other words a very low oxygen content
this would be a big problem for most
fish but it doesn't bother the arapaima
in fact being able to breathe air in low
oxygen environments
actually gives them a competitive
advantage in hunting
while other fish are moving more slowly
to deal with less oxygen in the water
the arapaima can still shoot forward at
full speed to capture prey
arapaima are a formidable predator in
the waters of the amazon
they trap prey by opening their mouths
in a way that creates suction
sucking fish crabs and even birds and
small mammals into their jaws
from there the prey is crushed between
their bony tongues
sharp upper palate and teeth not the
best way to go
in the amazon few animals sit higher on
the food chain
the only predators of these giant
creatures are jaguars
amazonian alligators and as you would
guess human beings
and even though arapaima regularly swim
in piranha-infested waters
they have an amazing adaptation that
protects them from being attacked
by schools of these dangerous fish
incredibly tough scales
arapaima skin makes up 10 of their body
weight
and is surprisingly useful for human
products
called leather the incredibly durable
material
is used for clothing purses and boots
and their scales are truly a marvel of
natural engineering
made up of two layers the scales are
both flexible
and tough meaning the fish can move
without any trouble
but are also very well protected from
puncture wounds
the top layer of the scales are actually
mineralized
making it almost like a flexible ceramic
it's similar to our bones
but all of the hard material is
collected at the surface
and the lower level is collagen fibrils
which grow in the pattern of a spiral
staircase
this structure means that even if the
hard outer layer is punctured
the collagen will break at different
angles and preserve the overall
integrity
it might be deformed but it won't
shatter like a window scientists are
studying the arapaima scales to see if
they can use it to improve
bulletproof armor which works similarly
by combining soft padding with a hard
plastic
but the problem is that this type of
armor requires a third material
a sealant to bind the two layers
together
in arapima the binding happens on a
molecular level
the two layers of the scale simply grow
together
which has proven difficult to replicate
in the lab
and on top of all of these impressive
adaptations
there's one that's so strange it has
perplexed both locals and scientists for
years something that seems like it
shouldn't come from a fish
at all
when you think of the animals that care
for their young you probably think of
animals like us
the primates elephants dogs or cats
in fact all mammals care for their young
because all mammals by definition
provide milk for their babies sometimes
for months and months
most fish in the world by contrast
simply lay their eggs somewhere safe
and then bounce but for generations
indigenous people of the amazon have
observed something baffling
arapaima producing what looks like milk
and their babies swimming through it
the creamy white fluid comes out of
cavities in the skull of both male and
female arapaima during the reproductive
period
for a long time people thought this was
some kind of nursing strategy
but in 2017 researchers analyzed the
chemical compounds of the milk and were
surprised by what they found
instead of being full of protein like
milk would be
the cephalic fluid was a mixture of
hormones and chemicals that are related
to immunological processes
in other words the milk wasn't
nourishing the young
but it was clearly doing something
because there was an increase in its
production for both males and females
when they were having
offspring and the young fish seemed to
be absorbing it
one of the hormones they found is called
prolactin
this was perplexing prolactin is the
hormone that mainly stimulates breast
growth and production of milk in mammals
but the arapaima milk isn't really milk
like ours is
here prolactin must be serving a
different purpose
in mammals and birds prolactin is also
known to enter the brain to affect
neuronal function
inducing parental behavior in one study
rodents were found to retrieve and groom
their pups more often with more
prolactin in their system
in birds prolactin increases parental
behavior like nesting
incubation and feeding researchers think
that in
fish prolactin could be increasing
parental behavior
just as it does in the other vertebrates
and the arapaima
are indeed caring parents not only do
the parents build a nest
to hold the eggs and then guard it from
predators the males also help the little
fish for up to three months after they
hatch
the male's head turn a darker color
perhaps to offer camouflage to their
young
and they sometimes bring the fry into
their mouths to move them to another
location if predators get too close
scientists also think the arapaima milk
could work as a chemoattractant
keeping the offspring close to the head
of the male keeping them safer and
causing them to follow as he searches
for plankton-rich water that they can
feed in
overall arapaima babies who are exposed
to the arapaima milk
grow bigger and are more likely to
survive compared to ones who are raised
without the milk
but unfortunately there's still a lot
researchers are struggling to understand
about the behavior and life cycle of
this giant fish
and that's partially because in some
parts of the amazon
arapaima came very close to extinction
for millions of years arapaima used
their many adaptations to rule the
amazon river
but with the arrival of more and more
humans we eventually became
their main hunters and even though the
giant fish are well adapted to withstand
predation from almost any other creature
their need to rise to the surface for
air makes them very appealing targets
for humans with sharp sticks
for centuries local indigenous people
relied on arapaima for sustenance
without causing
any strong negative impact to the
populations
but the combination of outsiders coming
in to catch the fish
and locals catching an increasing number
of arapaima to sell commercially
the populations around brazil and guyana
plummeted
but there's strong evidence that
protecting the fish and creating
restrictions for when the fish can be
harvested
can be very effective in helping the
arapaima populations rebound
in communities in brazil protective
measures like catch limits and a total
fishing ban at certain times of the year
allowed the populations to grow over 400
in eight years lakes that had only 20
arapaima left
ended up with more than two thousand but
of course
arapaima live across a wide geographical
range
and conditions are different from one
place to another in some places
mining and deforestation are a big
threat in others the commercial
over-harvesting of the arapaima is the
main problem
different communities respond with
different solutions
based on their needs take riwa village
in guyana for example
the arapaima were traditionally an
important source of nutrition for the
local indigenous people
but overfishing led to a huge decrease
in their population
with help from scientists who
established surveys to monitor the range
and population size of the arapaima
the village was able to create
regulations to protect the fish in their
area
they also built an eco lodge and started
a fishing business that offered catch
and release programs to anglers visiting
the region for tourism
not only does this program prevent
arapaima from being killed
it also provides income for the
villagers who previously relied on over
harvesting the fish for their
income and the scientists who work in
guyana have suggested taking arapaima
conservation one step
further because arapaima used the
floodplains as part of their habitat
there's a strong need to protect the
forests as well as the river
when it comes to policy makers deciding
what parts of the forest to protect
ensuring the survival of arapaima
requires extending protections beyond
the dry season banks of the amazon
and this kind of protection could help a
number of other species who make their
homes in the forests as well as the
river
there's still a lot we don't know about
the arapaima but with any luck
helping protect the means they'll
continue to reign as the giants of the
amazon
and give us plenty of chances to learn
more about them
the arapaima and all of its strangeness
is a product of its wild and
unpredictable habitat
the extreme seasonal flooding of the
amazon has shaped its evolution for
millions of years
it's a phenomenon that turns the forest
floor into the riverbed
huge stretches of land underwater for
six months of the year
these floods create thousands of river
islands in an archipelago that stretches
for
thousands of kilometers the largest
collection of river islands in the world
the arapaima is not the only creature
who has been forged from these watery
circumstances
these river islands are home to some of
the most unusual creatures
everything living there during the
floods is forced to adapt or die
in the documentary amazon river islands
the floating forest on curiosity stream
you can learn about the fish that feed
from the treetops floating islands of
ants
and the trees and plants that have
learned to survive for months underwater
it's an episode in a series called
wildest islands
all of which gives you a glimpse into
some of the most interesting micro
habitats around the world
curiosity stream is a streaming platform
with thousands of high quality
documentaries like this one
and now curiositystream has partnered
with us to offer an incredible deal
by signing up to curiositystream you now
also get a subscription to nebula
nebula is a streaming platform made by
me and several other educational youtube
content creators
it's a place where we can upload our
videos ad free
and a place where we can experiment with
new original content
one of these new projects for us is our
podcast called modulus
it's available ad-free on nebula and is
where we explore the human stories
behind the science we cover here on
youtube
in the latest episode brian from real
engineering
interviews bawback ferdowsi a nasa
engineer who takes us inside the arc of
his career
the make or break moments behind the
mars curiosity rover
and his rise to overnight celebrity so
by
signing up at curiositystream.com real
science
you'll get a subscription to curiosity
stream and a subscription to nebula
for just 14.79 for the entire year
signing up is also the best way to
support this channel
and all of your favorite educational
content creators
thanks for watching and if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my
instagram
twitter and patreon are below
[Music]
you